so when should you use plugins and when
is it best to stay away that's what
we're talking about in today's video
podcast
[Music]
hey there and welcome to the motion
science video podcast my name is Cameron
and today we're talking about plugins
and more specifically when should you
use them and when should you stay away
from them so let's talk about the first
when to stay away from plugins because
the reason I'm addressing this is I get
asked a lot of what plugins should I use
is this plug-in better than this plug-in
I see a lot of motion designers really
focused on plugins and that's kind of a
dangerous thing when we don't understand
as a motion designer what it takes to
build amazing motion design without the
plugins that's when we put out work that
isn't so awesome
okay so when should you not use plugins
you should not use plugins when you're
going for the cool factor okay if you're
just saying like I'm gonna add this
plug-in it's gonna make my work look
amazing it's gonna look so cool stay
away from the plugins right that's
that's a bad sign you should also not
use a plug-in because it's trendy I see
this all the time
a company will put out an advertisement
like hey here's a new plug-in you've got
to check this out and all of a sudden
it's everywhere it's everywhere ok it
can be a globe plug-in that's everywhere
it can be a chromatic aberration plug-in
it's everywhere it can be a particle
system it's everywhere and all of a
sudden because it's so trendy because
it's the new hot plug in all the work
that I see on the socials starts to look
the same so don't use a plug-in because
it's trendy now there's nothing wrong
with just jumping in and diving in and
kind of exploring that plug-in because
you know when a plugin comes out or
script even um they're made for a
specific purpose and that purpose could
be to save as time and energy right
which is a big thing with motion design
motion design for really good motion
design takes a lot of time yes it takes
a lot of time like I get a satellite
like is it
taking a long time to make this yes if
you want to look awesome
it's simply gonna take some time to make
it and people are often surprised
especially new motion designers how long
it takes to make good motion design but
if a plugin comes along and it can help
you know speed that process up I'm all
for it but don't do it just because it's
trendy and everyone else is doing it a
third reason is not to use a plug-in is
thinking it's going to make your work
look better and this kind of comes back
to the cool factor which was number one
to have really awesome motion design to
have your work look like other designers
out there that you admire you have to
start at the bottom right you have to
not saying that you have to start at the
bottom of the race you have to start at
the base of what makes good motion
design right now if you want to learn
how to do that go check out style craft
I show you what the elements and the
principles of good design and animation
are that will make your work stellar
right it will up level you also check
out Pro flows there's techniques in
there and now it does focus more on how
how would you do something but there's
also a lot of Y in there for why it
looks better and that's what you have to
understand right you gotta understand
what makes good motion design that
that's a lot of different things but if
your work isn't solid at that base level
then when you put a plug-in on it to
make it look cool it's not gonna look
cool I'm sorry to say you know like for
me personally I love glow plugins right
now just bashed on some glow plugins but
I do love glow I love it I feel I've
used it for years years and years and
years and it looks cool but if my base
motion design doesn't look cool to begin
with then adding that polish that glow
on the top is just gonna make it you
know what they say shine a turd shine a
turd is that what they say I don't know
I'm terrible with sayings but same goes
for like right now for chromatic
aberration chromatic aberrations
everywhere at least in the pro world I
see it everywhere sometimes it's very
very subtle sometimes it's really
over-the-top
too much
typically the times that it's
over-the-top this is a great example
it's over the top because a motion
designer thinks hey everyone's using
chromatic aberration it's trendy it's
cool I'm gonna apply it to my work and
it's gonna make it look that much better
and you can tell that that's the case
because the chromatic aberrations in
your face right it's just too much it's
not it should be subtle same goes for
glitching I see it all the time with
motion designers just throwing on glitch
on a random project and I'm not here to
diss on you we're here to learn but
you're not gonna take a piece like Eddie
you know just like I've seen corporate
pieces where all of a sudden you're
watching a corporate video and there's a
glitch transition to the next shot and
it's like well hold on like why was
there a glitch there like it doesn't
make it makes absolutely zero sense but
glitching was so trendy everyone's using
glitch effects right and that's not the
reason to use a plug-in not the reason
so let's talk about now when you should
use plugins okay a great use of a
plug-in is when you have a specific set
of tasks that you need to accomplish
like I mentioned earlier particles okay
if you have a particle system excuse me
your work you've been hired to create a
piece around particles or you want to
create a spec piece around particle
systems well then of course you want to
use a particle plugin like now there are
built-in plugins inside of After Effects
that create particles like particle
systems particle world I'll be honest
I've never douve very deep into those
because there are particle generators
like from red giant trapcode particular
I've been using particular since the
beginning whenever I need to use a
particle system that's where I go right
because I know that plug-in and it's
there for a specific purpose I'm not
going to use it for things like magic
dust and things like that I don't get
hard to do those type of projects
there's nothing wrong with using it for
that kind of stuff but you know there's
so many cases of using particle
systems for a specific project right the
same can go for like physics-based like
there's plugins like Newton right and
Newton is there as a plug-in to make
your workflow faster when you have to
have things like bouncing or falling and
reacting to real-world physics well
that's when a plug-in like Newton is
ideal to use okay because it has a very
specific task it's going to speed up
your workflow to do that and you've been
hired to do this physics based motion
design piece um another specific example
is like when I love neon right and I've
been teaching neon and pro flows and
impro flows almost all my lessons were
based around a plug-in called saber from
Video Copilot and the reason I love
saber so much is because number one it's
a free plug-in from Video Copilot and
anything they put out it's amazing as we
all know and it does such a stellar job
of creating neon looks that it's like
why wouldn't I go to that immediately
because I know that I can create some
some mass or some typography and throw
this plug-in on there and it's gonna
meet if a few adjustments look like neon
right it saves me so much time I use it
specifically for neon every time I
create neon I'm using saber toy use it
for anything else no but I know for neon
effects I'm going to jump into that and
you know neons really hot right now the
time of this recording anyways it's
really very popular and it's a it's a
powerful plug-in I'm also going to use
plugins for what I call the polish okay
again I talked a lot about the polish
and style craft the Polish is the last
10 15 20 percent of a project that
already looks stellar it looks so good
and you have this project looks so great
your client season says wow that's
amazing
now you apply this last 10 15 20 percent
the Polish
that's your plugins that's when you're
applying your subtle glows and your
subtle chromatic aberrations
your subtle like dusts or grains things
like that that just add that little
extra oomph to that piece to push it
over the edge and just to make an
amazing piece okay that's the polish
that's for me that's actually the number
one reason to use plugins it's at the
very end you really create that final
look based on the polish know I love
certain plugins that can do that for me
like sapphire
that's my suite of plugins that is by
far the be-all end-all if I could only
use one set of plugins there would be
sapphire right and they have a lot of
plugins built into it but that they
create the final polish another reason
to when to use plugins is when you're
Craney trying to create a specific look
at the end okay
so again this is you building up a piece
80% there 90% there and you need to
finish it out with that final look and
maybe that look is like for me I love
like old film looks right and or a
grungy looking and there are certain
plugins I know specifically that that
can create that old film look without me
having to go I could go into After
Effects and I could create a stack of
adjustment layers and I could create you
know scratches and grains and dust and
flicker and exposure and film jitters
things like that layer after layer after
layer or I could save myself an entire
day or four hours or five hours by just
applying my favorite film look plugins
at the end now when I apply those for
that specific look I rarely ever apply
the plug-in and say hey it's good to go
there's the preset it's good to go I
rarely rarely rarely ever do that it's
always best to take that initial preset
and I dive into it and I just fine-tune
it for my work what what needs to be
adjusted what needs to be cranked up or
cranked down for my piece that it's
applied to
okay and my last reason reason number
five for when to use a plug-in is if
it's a specific time-saving plugin like
one of my favorites animation composer
okay if you're not familiar with the
animation composer go check it out it's
by mr. horse TV it is such a time saver
when I want to do simple animations and
I want to try things out and this is
just one specific plugin that I'm
talking about there's a lot of these
plugins out there that save you time but
plugins that specifically are made to
save you time what I love about the
animation composer animation composer is
that I can go through hundreds of
presets and just click click two clicks
and they're applied to my typography
animation to my camera animation to my
my shape animation whatever it is and I
could immediately see what things are
gonna look like with two clicks versus
typing in a lot of expressions or
manipulating keyframes yes I get I get I
get like
push backs on this thing well it's just
a pre-made preset no you never take a
preset and just leave it as is
I like to take presets I like to combine
presets I like to fine tune those those
parameters are that preset but these
these plugins that are made to save you
time and energy we're always trying to
save energy our brains are wired for us
to always save energy right and so and
that's a scientific fact I'm not just
making this up so we want to save time
and that's what those plugins that's
when they come in and they're like I
said there's a lot of them out there but
those are the ones those are the times
you you should use plugins so just to
recap don't use a fact don't use a
plug-in for a cool factor because it's
trendy or because you think it's going
to make your work look better it
probably won't
don't use plugins for that when to use a
plug-in if you have a specific set of
tasks you're trying to accomplish a
specific like particle systems or
physics if or you have a plug-in that
has a very specific look like a neon
look like saber
right or use it for polish which is the
last 10 15 20 % of your project you've
already got the base there you're
applying the Polish use it for a
specific look at the end like glows and
chromatic aberrations or film looks
whatever it is and use it for a specific
as a time-saver something a plugin that
can save you time time is money and
while we're getting paid by a client if
we can save ourselves some time and
speed up the process we're all winners
right so there you go that's when you
should use plugins and when you should
stay away from as always thanks for
taking the time to watch this video and
until next time I'm Cameron and this is
motion science see ya
[Music]